[Music]
I don't smell like ass that's about all
I know about them is that they smell too
bad
yeah it's like your freezer when you
don't clean it out seems pretty harmless
right now I'm not sure when all the
hullabaloo is all about
ah is it soft I feel like this is how
we're gonna die like an alien's gonna
pop out like does it smell you smell I
can start to smell it it's so bad I
couldn't this smells like a melon Oh
smells like wet garbage trash old eggs
cantaloupe passion fruit old
refrigerator oh oh oh it's like we
opened a freaking big chicken or
something just looks like mayonnaise and
body parts so I don't know what part you
supposed to eat oh I actually don't
think that I'm gonna be able to eat this
1 2 3
[Music]
[Applause]
melon with the texture of an uncooked
egg Oh - Lee tastes pretty good
definitely not worth the work kind of
mean to you when you're trying to eat it
if that's not good but then you get like
a whiff and it doesn't do it and then
like parts of it does taste ok then you
get a bite that's like not okay you can
wear a nose plug and have a good time
with some Darian it's like the box of
chocolates but a bad box of chocolates
you don't know what you're gonna get
[Music]